[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be continuing our discussion
around the casting of the much hyped HBO
reboot of the Harry Potter series to
date I've covered many of the main
characters introduced in the
Philosopher's Stone and the Chamber of
Secrets so in today's video I'll be
focusing on some of the central
characters from one of my personal
favorites the Prisoner of Azkaban let's
get started Aunt Marge a fairly
inconsequential yet hard to forget
character you likely remember the rather
rude sister of Vernon dursley Aunt Marge
featured only in the beginning of the
Prisoner of Azkaban Marge's lack of
compassion and general demeanor towards
an orphaned Harry is incredibly
offensive and ultimately leads to her
being blown up like a balloon by Harry's
use of inadvertent magic in the films
Aunt Marge or Marjorie Island dursley if
you will was portrayed by German actress
Pam Varys I had absolutely no complaint
about this casting at the time I thought
Pam was quite entertaining in the role
and she did a terrific job of making me
hate her so in recasting Aunt Marge I'd
be tempted to give the role to another
actress who I know could absolutely nail
the callousness and self-righteousness
of March Margot Martindale Margot has
appeared in an incredible amount of film
and television and has brought
characters similar to aren't marched to
life with great results I personally
feel that she would also be able to
bring a certain amount of agreeability
to the role which would make her very
interesting to watch indeed my only
hesitation is the fact that she's
American and I can't comment on her
ability to do an English accent she may
also be a little on the older side to
play Aunt Marge but this will largely
depend on who they cast as petunia and
Vernon dursley Sirius Black in the
original film Sirius Black Harry's
estranged Godfather and former member of
the Marauders was played by none other
than Gary Oldman while I have nothing
against Gary Oldman and his performance
of Sirius the casting to me never felt
quite right of course much of this had
to do with this age in the novels Sirius
was meant to be in his early 30s and
while it's true that he was described as
having undergone a fair bit of physical
trauma due in large part to his time
spent in Azkaban amongst the
soul-sucking Dementors he was still said
to be Darkly handsome casually elegant
and well young while I do understand the
choice to cast an older actor the
filmmakers would have need to age
serious up to align with Alan Rickman
Severus Snape as I said it just never
quite worked for me with this in mind I
must admit that I hope the casting for
the new Harry Potter series will be more
in line with the novels which is
probably why I find the fan casting
choice of British actor Ben Barnes to be
a rather interesting one evidently fans
first put Ben up for the role more than
a decade ago when there was hope that a
prequel series focusing on the Marauders
May one day get made alas that was not
to be and at this point Ben would be too
old to play a teenage Sirius Black
anyway but he's certainly not too old to
portray an adult one with many film and
television credits under his belt from
The Chronicles of Narnia to Dorian Gray
and even his most recent role in
Netflix's Shadow and Bone Ben is no
stranger to film universes that have
been built on loyal fandom and Magic I
think he could definitely pull off the
haughty yet compassionate complexities
of areas and while he looks rather young
Ben Barnes is actually in his early 40s
so his age Works another option I think
would be worth considering for the role
of Sirius Black is kid Harrington kit is
most well known for his portrayal of Jon
Snow in the Game of Thrones television
series he's about the right age he's got
the accent and his depth of range of
emotion has been well established on
screen of course both these options only
work if Snape is also cast in his 30s
since all of these actors will need to
be around the same age Remus Lupine the
Beloved werewolf Marauder and former
best friend of James Potter was
originally played by David dulis again
back in the 2000s I was thrown by this
casting Choice as he was quite a bit
older than I had pictured him while
reading the books but as with Gary
Oldman David thulis did a marvelous job
at embodying the character of Remus
Lupine and his age made sense when
matched up with the other characters of
Snape and Sirius and so who would I
recast in this role the large majority
of fans seem to wish to see Andrew
Garfield as the new Remus Lupine and
while he's about the same age as say
Adam Driver a fan favorite to play Snape
and Ben Barnes I'm not so sure I agree I
think if Andrew Garfield does end up in
this role I wouldn't be upset about it I
can see what fans are getting at but he
wouldn't be my first choice instead I'd
rather see someone like Daniel Sharman a
lesser known actor born and raised in
London who began his career the Royal
Shakespeare company he's about the right
age and to me he gives off the right
balance of compassion and Melancholy
needed for the role he's also got
experience playing a werewolf in a
television series Teen Wolf
one other British actor who I think
could do well in the role is Joseph
Quinn best known for his role as Eddie
Munson in the fourth season of stranger
things I think Joseph would be able to
embody a warmth of character that
perhaps Daniel sharman's Lupine would
lack that said Joseph Quinn is in his
late 20s and may be too young for the
role Peter Pettigrew originally
portrayed by Timothy spall an
award-winning classical character actor
this role is a tricky one to cast once
again Timothy spall did an incredible
job bringing the character of worm tell
to life in terms of casting however I'd
personally like to see the new HBO
series Focus a little less on the
rat-like appearance of wormtail and more
on his actual character I do understand
the filmmakers were likely trying to
Showcase what living as a rat for over a
decade had done to Peter and his
physical attributes but it all felt a
bit much to me now I've seen many fans
suggest Dane DeHaan an American actor as
their top choice for Peter Pettigrew but
to me Dane is too young looking to play
a 30-something-year-old wormtail and I
haven't seen him perform without his
American accent so I can't comment on
his ability to do so instead I would
personally cast Jimmy Bell the British
actor known for his portrayal of the
titular role of Billy in Billy Elliot
Jamie looks about the right age and
presents an air of underdogged Innocence
that I think would perfectly embody
Peter Pettigrew you know before he
betrayed everyone he claimed to care for
I think Jaime would also add a bit of a
something to prove chip on his shoulder
to his performance which would keep
things interesting and perhaps provide
the audience with more insight into why
this former Marauder betrayed his best
friends in favor of a psychopathic
Wizarding Overlord Professor Sybil
trelawny I must admit that Professor
Sybil trelawny was never a favorite
character of mine that is until the
incredible Emma Thompson was cast as a
quirky somewhat Charming version of the
witch in my opinion Emma provided a
hilarity and absurdity to the role that
was grounded in a lovable ineptitude I
thought it was brilliant whoever fills
this role certainly has big shoes to
fill recasting this character was
definitely the most difficult one for me
in today's video I was looking for
someone with the ability to be
believably useless entitled and
unknowingly Brilliant all at the same
time while also convincingly pulling off
the insane attire Sybil chooses to dress
herself in I finally found someone who I
think would be an excellent choice for
the part of Professor trelawny Juno
Temple a seasoned actress with credits
dating back to the early 2000s you'll
likely know her from her most recent
role as Keeley Jones and the Apple TV
head Ted lasso she can be innocent funny
sassy intelligent and a whole lot more I
think she would do great things with
this role and with that we've come to
the end of another video what did you
think do you agree with my casting
choices disagree who would you like to
see playing these characters please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to do a long
dreams and forget to live